hätten sie ihn erkannt der magier david
copperfield vor gericht in las vegas ein
58 jähriger britischer tourist wirft ihm
vor sich bei einem seiner tricks
verletzt zu haben will 400.000 us dollar
in einem hotel in las vegas sei das
geschehen im november 2013 beim trick
lucky number verdiene und der geht so
13 menschen werden auf die bühne geführt
einen vorhang vorgezogen dann wieder weg
die menschen scheinen plötzlich
verschwunden im hinteren teil der bühne
tauchen sie dann wieder auf gewinnkurs
behauptet er und die anderen zwölf
zuschauer seien durch einen dunklen
verstellten gang in den hinteren bereich
der bühne gelangt er sei gestürzt und
habe sich die schulter ausgekugelt
copperfields anwälte wollten die
offenbarung des tricks verhindern
argumentierten dass die marke david
copperfield dadurch geschädigt werden
könnte die richter aber hatten kein
einsehen der prozesse und in den
kommenden tagen fortgesetzt werden